the Xbox holiday update is out now  consider it an early present for  Microsoft I'm Tony this is a game spot  news update and this is what xbox is  bringing to the table first the holiday  update adds clubs and the looking for  group feature both should come in handy  if you're looking to form a crew online  the new group messaging option will make  that even easier especially if you're  fond of sending emojis achievements are  getting some tweaks to including a new  sound for any rare ones you unlock and  gamerscore leaderboards will refresh  every 30 days to see who's earned the  most that month the holiday update is  pushing out now so you should see the  option shortly if you haven't already as  for what's next for Microsoft the big  thing on the horizon is project Scorpio  headed to store shelves and holiday 2017  you can expect plenty more updates to  the console in the meantime but for all  the latest on xbox you're already in the  right place